the kona company in northern Germany
makes trailers for large trucks with the
transport and logistics sector growing
exponentially Kona's trailers have never
been in such high demand and not only in
Europe right now management is keeping a
close watch on developments in Turkey
where Kona has just invested 38 million
euros in a production plant even if
things go up and down in the country we
don't simply pull out like capital
investment which reacts like a startled
deer that's the advantage of mid-sized
companies family-owned Kona thinks in
terms of generations both in Germany and
in its plant close to Izmir this company
video there shows the production of
trailers destined for Turkey Central
Asia and Africa despite the political
upheaval in Turkey M's 'land
headquarters is staying calm management
keeps abreast of the situation via
regular video conferences Kona's
Managing Director in Turkey says it's
business as usual right now it's not
like we'd say oh my god we've got it
slam on the brakes we're getting
inquiries which is good of course things
will cool down a little but I think
that's only natural after such major
events but for many German companies
Turkey has become a shaky prospect
that's especially true in parts of the
country that maintained close economic
ties to the Bosphorus the head of
colognes Chamber of Commerce and
Industry Alexander Hercules has fond
memories of Turkey but now he says a lot
of his clients are cautious when it
comes to fresh investment we have to
understand that Turkey has a very high
load of foreign debt that means the
country depends on foreign capital to
meet its obligations and we're seeing
that the uncertainty there is growing
and recently investments are tending to
slow
Kona is one of the exceptions it started
up its own Turkish sales network and
just this may built a spare parts
facility near Istanbul you're always
gonna have cycles be they about
financial technicalities or currency
fluctuations or party issues or
political situations something's always
going on in Turkey you just have to
accept it and live up to your commitment
and given Kona's total sales of more
than a billion euros a year the company
views its commitments in Turkey is still
manageable